look at this guy look at this guy
oh [ __ ] he's great like this guy so
[Music]
Gareth I brought you here today wine to
show you one of the greats let's just go
into it don't want I don't want the time
when I brought you all the way over here
to my place let's just roll it a is for
Adam Oh for Adam who's about to learn
who's gonna learn my head hurts
I don't like Adams in science general
electric company one of the best
animating companies out there first a
trick for sure yes so great okay
realistic control of atomic weapon yes
can and will be achieved
yes requires that all of us prepare for
any of it oh my it's time I watch
demands to that we take time to
understand this force because here in
fact is the answer to a dream as old as
man himself that's what I atom bombs big
guys Wow so until the United Nations can
figure this all out get comfortable with
the big giant atom man we got rid of
this building yeah yeah and stripped it
site we don't have that anymore you're
like okay little man big but oh [ __ ] get
him a doctor
hello okay so this prison professor who
pokes at his own brain yeah he digs
around in there and by what professor
just where's this graduation camp all
the time there
our other differences - hey hold it
thank you now the solar system gather is
electrical the electrons which are
negative are attracted by Oh Dave I
don't need to hear my girlfriend Tommy
was yeah nuclear is where it gets crazy
of neutrons largest to attract neutrons
protons when it comes to atomic energy
you're positive
beer no party atom's nucleus together
uh-huh
see you sure yeah
thank God what an entertaining cartoon
look kids had it better back then they'd
wake up they learn a little bit about
nuclear your honor oh good the elements
I was just gonna say let's get into
those of the individual they look like
that a scientist wait kids the kid Adam
Brooke he's got our head darling the
number of neutrons it's just fun yeah
now this is cool again yeah okay so yeah
okay right and let me guess you that's a
crazy finish didn't see that coming
that's an M night Shyamalan Cole I'm
glad I came here to learn about ten you
know that they call that in England
aluminium no matter
oh I understand the path you've led me
down you've brilliantly this guy look at
this guy
oh [ __ ] he's gray like this guy what
they've added him whoa there he goes to
another family fine was tired from his
big day of becoming stable development
and then learning yeah I'm learning a
lot I feel like they needed an editor or
some
just give notes done what about less
protons
no no there is
look at that evolution stuck as a copy
machine and then that guy atom smashers
there they are the bad guys is exciting
oh you're sleepy I'm excited I'm excited
to yawn learn so that is a shoe worn and
lima beans
oh that looks YUM that's what was
happening in your stomach at the San
Francisco show what do they put their
shooter Neutron at the hello truly a
discovery to change the world it's gonna
be great nothing bad is gonna happen
from this nothing keep saying miracle
keep saying miracle don't forget to say
miracle together you know this takes me
back to when I was a boy and also
couldn't understand it it explodes as
energy proving Einstein's theory that
man is really the same but we spoke of a
double miracle double America I was just
saying slow down sweat my one note slow
down look how much do you think the
narrator actually understood failing 2%
reasoning it was like as long as the
check clears
the result a chain reaction oh boy
so hey we did it we killed a bunch of
Japanese people bama's America does
baseball the time the free world here we
go here we go yeah yeah I love that
the first thought obviously weapon we've
got something good on our hands then
you're way way too into detail I don't
agree no my dad used to have reactor
plows out back oh yeah I remember yeah
you told me about it's been hours this
is so great
hey I like my propaganda catchy why does
it gotta go in that way guess where
we're headed right up the oh oh oh what
happens one guy takes Molly the other
guy it's like The Odd Couple of Adam's
right remember the chain reaction
process in the reactor creates
tremendous heat oh my god I'm gonna go
home and build one of things I can't
believe the detail on this Oh
nuclear power show there's a show cuz
the show come to the show that's right
nuclear train wheels nuclear train and
nuclear submarines created the big man
big strong man when armies guys yes let
me help you let me heat your homes I
guess I'm just gonna hold this because
I'm super powerful
I'm the Academy Award I thought back
then like they would have like the two
knees
[Music]
we are that man so inspires children
children oh my god you know babies yay
oh my god by the way this works out
great for Japan oh not now Dave don't be
a party pooper just what I realize how
good it was all good well and that's why
General Electric is known as one of the
great filmmakers and nuclear power ist's
[Music]
you